cuando pensamos en brasil lo más
probable es que nos vengan a la cabeza
cosas tan típicas como la samba la
caipirinha el cristo de corcovado o
playas tan increíbles como ipanema o
copacabana
en definitiva el sitio perfecto para
desconectarlo sin embargo si le
preguntamos a un brasileño puede que la
imagen de su país no sea exactamente esa
hoy en visual político te contamos la
parte menos bonita de brasil
brasil está sufriendo y su peor recesión
de los años 30 o quizás la mayor de
todos los tiempos sólo en el primer
trimestre del 2016 el pib cayó un 56 por
ciento respecto al mismo periodo
anterior
brasil está replicando su década perdida
de los 80 en tan sólo dos años en
cuestión de dos años el número de
desempleados ha pasado de 7 millones a
11 la crisis y la caída en el precio del
petróleo ha afectado a la recaudación de
impuestos de forma severa de hecho el
actual gobernador del estado de río de
janeiro francisco dornelles declaró el
pasado 17 de junio el estado de
calamidad pública
el objetivo del decreto es presentar a
la sociedad de río de janeiro las
dificultades del estado abriendo camino
a medidas duras abriendo jamil
permitidos duros el épico y previsto
para el estado de río de janeiro este
año es de cinco mil seiscientos millones
de dólares un 30 por ciento sus ingresos
parece que el problema comenzó cuando la
época del boom del petróleo se dedicaron
a subir salarios y pensiones haciéndolo
ahora insostenible
a día de hoy maestros médicos policías y
bomberos tienen problemas para cobrar
sus salarios bienvenidos al infierno la
policía y los bomberos no cobran
y cualquiera que venga río de janeiro no
estará seguro para que os hagáis una
idea la cosa llega hasta el punto que la
morgue de la ciudad de río controlada
por la policía estatal dejó de aceptar
cuerpos a principios del mes de junio
porque no tenían dinero para hacerse
cargo de la limpieza tiene que mandar
los cadáveres a otras ciudades es
tremendo
como recordaréis en las próximas semanas
se celebrarán las olimpiadas de río 2016
y esta situación ha afectado de lleno a
las olimpiadas el estado de río de
janeiro es el responsable de la
seguridad y de la construcción del metro
que une la villa olímpica con el centro
de la ciudad y nuestra del todo claro
que pueda estar en funcionamiento a
tiempo el gobierno federal se ha
comprometido a mandar unidades militares
para reforzar la seguridad aún así el
problema no parece del todo resuelto y
algunos como el famoso jugador brasileño
rivaldo están viendo a la gente que no
ha rendido su vida por ir a ver a
olimpia
las olimpiadas han sido por cierto otro
gran escándalo en brasil y es que la
policía federal ha incluido dentro de la
aparición cargos el mayor caso de
corrupción investigado de la estrella al
país varios proyectos milmillonarios
relacionados directamente con las
olimpiadas los encargados de esta macro
operación están investigando a
importantes políticos del país como el
ex presidente fernando color el
presidente el senado bernanke leirós y
el que más revuelo creado el ex
presidente lula da silva que fue
detenido el pasado mes de marzo
relacionado con operaciones de lavado de
dinero
la intención política en brasil es en
estos momentos del todo inestable el
pasado 12 de mayo el senado brasileño
suspendió a la presidenta dilma rousseff
del cargo por un periodo hasta 180 días
acusada de manipular datos oficiales la
contabilidad del gobierno mientras que
el 73 por ciento de los brasileños
valoran el gobierno de rousseff como
malo o terrible con el permite además de
aprobación de un presidente brasileño
desde el año 92
bueno pues dilma denuncia que se ha
cometido un golpe de estado contra ella
que estáis wow
lo que está en juego es el respeto a la
voluntad soberana del pueblo brasileño
el respeto a las urnas
michel temer vicepresidente del gobierno
de rousseff ha sido designado mientras
tanto como presidente temer ha sido
criticar nada más llegar por nombrar un
gobierno compuesto sólo de hombres y
además blancos aunque lleva escasamente
más semanas en el poder dos de sus
ministros han tenido que dimitir ya
relacionados con escuchas en esa
criticaban a los investigadores del caso
cargos uno de ellos era el encargado de
luchar contra corrupción en materia
económica los planes de temer son claros
recortar al máximo posible el gasto
desorbitado el gobierno que ha crecido a
un nivel del 6% durante los últimos 20
años y luego tratar de la seguridad a
los inversores internacionales
para tener nuevo capital al país
cuantos que creéis los políticos de
brasil serán capaces de acabar con la
corrupción generalizada en el país es
razonable que un país en esta situación
se gaste miles de millones en construir
todas las infraestructuras necesarias
para acelerar durante unos días unas
olimpiadas sin duda deberemos estar
atentos los próximos meses a las
noticias que nos llegan desde brasil si
os ha preocupado el break sheet nos
debería preocupar mucho más aún un
hundimiento sin retorno de la economía
brasileña espero todos vuestros
comentarios si os ha gustado el vídeo
darle a light y suscribiros al canal si
aún no lo habéis hecho pasar tanto de
nuestros nuevos vídeos un saludo y hasta
la próxima